The immigration hamster charge,
which is a fee paid for the NHS,
the British healthcare system,
as part of the process for many visas
he sets to increase from January 2024.
I must like the Northern Increase
Immigration Household Charge
to be approved by both parliaments,
the house of Commons and the house of Lords,
to come into force from 16th January 2024
or if after that date
at the latest,
on the 21st day
after the date on which the order is approved.
Immigration health recharge will increase from
four hundred and seventy per year to 776 per year
for visas for children,
students and their dependents
and workers
here under the youth mobility visa
increase from 624 per year,
2,035 per year for all the visas
such as family visas,
for example,
visas for partners,
fiance's spouse
among orders
and workers
and entrepreneur visas.
Ideal for those
who already meet the requirements of the visa routes
would be to apply now or before 16th January 2024,
that is, before the 66% fee increases.